foreign
[Music]
I'm an art conservator and the director
of conservation at center Art Studio in
New York City
today I'm going to walk you through how
we restore a 16th century sculpture of
St George
this sculpture is owned by a collector
in New York City and he brought the
sculpture to us when it was damaged in
transit from Barcelona
the first thing we do when we get an
object into the studio tourist store is
perform an initial inspection
so we want to understand what is the
current condition of the object
and once we understand that then we are
able to start formulating a treatment
plan
this is a sculpture of Saint George
slaying a dragon
the the lores that the villagers had to
sacrifice somebody to this Dragon every
year and then one year it became the
princess of the town that was going to
be sacrificed and so St George Soldier
came in slayed the dragon saved the
princess and you know has been revered
in his estate
this is a depiction of St George but it
actually has the face and the hair of
King Ferdinand II
clearly it's very well carved that's
polychrome gilded
it is a significant piece that would
have been well funded
after we've come up with a treatment
plan the first thing that we do is
separate the figure dragon and face and
we are going to clean each one of those
components separately
it has a very very heavy glossy varnish
on top of it
which just is unnecessary it comes
across as heavy-handed we can tell that
there's dirt sitting under the top
varnish layer so that means that whoever
lasts varnished this piece and worked on
it didn't fully clean it properly they
put new coats of material over dirt and
bad Restorations
we start out with solvent gels and we
apply the gel to the surface and the gel
holds the solvent against the surface so
it it allows it to penetrate a little
bit better
when the gel is on the surface we come
in with a swab and kind of agitate the
gel to turn it over to make sure that
you know you know fresh clean gel is
making contact with that area that we're
cleaning
the most difficult component to clean
against the varnish off of is the base
just because it is so thick and heavy
and waxy
so that takes a bit more time and care
to remove
big look with a UV flashlight on the
surface and if we see green reflecting
back that indicates to us that there's a
yellowed varnish or coating on that
surface
it's typical to have us actually clean
with a flashlight so we can see where
we're removing those green areas
the face and the hands are they're very
dirty and with a proper cleaning they're
going to really transform from a kind of
a dull murky color to a bright skin
color that really is dramatically
different than how it looks pretty
cleaning
when we removed that gel that's cleaned
off all those layers we see it in that
cleaned area we see old crackle lines
and that crackle is desirable because it
just indicates the age of the piece and
you want to see you'd expect an object
from the 1500s to have lots of variation
and age to it so once you remove those
layers you start to see the complexity
of the surface and it just takes on a
whole new um substantial feeling
when art is in transit that's when it's
really at most risk of incurring damage
and unfortunately that's just what
happened in this case
it couldn't support itself I mean it's
meant to be a freestanding object and it
could not vertically support itself
to do those structural repairs on this
figure we have to remove the iron rods
that are going through the feet of St
George and into the dragon those are
held into the sculpture it was some kind
of bonding glue epoxy resin we're not
exactly sure what that is so we need to
break that bond in order to get those
rods out
this is obviously a very tricky delicate
procedure because we're going to have to
remove those rods but we really don't
want to cause any further damage so we
test a variety of methods so we will
chip off a bit of that compound and put
it in a vial of water or solvents and
and do a test to see we can see that if
that little chip dissolves
so we were able to determine that it
would soften in water but it didn't
dissolve it so we could use water to
help us but we're still going to have to
use drills and more mechanical
approaches
so we sort of break away that old epoxy
that's holding the rods into the
sculpture and we use vice grips and
clamps as we go we add a bit of water
while we're wiggling the rod to break
that Bond
ultimately we switch out those tools for
a drill at first we use a regular drill
bit to try to break it up a bit and then
we have to switch out to an extra long
drill bit because these recesses are
actually very deep
so we used an extra long drill bit to
drill out that compound and that
ultimately allows us to remove the rod
then we have to dig out the holes the
recesses where the rods were in order to
remove all of the epoxy and just start
fresh
so we use a drill with a Forester bit to
enlarge the holes to about the diameter
of an inch in order to have enough space
to take the new stainless steel rods and
the epoxy that we're going to put in
the iron rods that we took out were in
very deep deeper than they needed to be
so we're going to plug those holes with
little pieces of wooden dowel that will
use fish glue to glue into the recess
just to make the hole a little bit
shallower it works really well it's a
natural material it binds really well it
dries clear
it's literally just made from condensed
fish
[Music]
in order to prep the sculpture to
receive the rods we had to repair the
broken foot so we use conspiration
epoxies to reattach the broken
components of the foot together to make
it one piece again and then once it's
solid it's in a position to then take
the new rods
we test fit them into St George and the
Dragon and we hold up the sculpture so
we can align where everything is going
to fit together
and then we'll mark on the dragon where
the stainless steel rods meet it we use
our very old but very handy drill press
to drill out those recesses that we've
marked on the dragon so where we've
marked those circles that's where we're
going to draw and that will just create
the recess that will allow the rods to
sit
um sit onto the Dragon
then we attach the figure to the Dragon
at that point St George and the Dragon
become one object so they are bonded
together
then we have to hold it in position so
we'll tie up the sculpture and make sure
it stays in a stable position ideally
overnight while the epoxy fully cures
and becomes really hard the next morning
when we come back to the studio we can
untie it and it will hold its own and it
will be stable and able to stand up
after the star silver repairs they're
done we apply a final coat of shellac to
the entire object we use a thin coat of
shellac you can always add more and
build it up but we always start with a
thin coat and see how that looks
typically you don't need a very heavy
coat it's unnecessary and it it just
presents better if there's less sitting
on top of the surface this was a
significant project there was a lot of
work that went into it so there were
weeks of active work
I'd say about five or six of our
conservators had their hand in restoring
St George
I'm very satisfied with this restoration
I think work we did was not
insignificant it was a major undertaking
it was I think a very successful project
and we all feel very accomplished that
we were able to restore it and get it
back to this point
we're very happy with it
it's it's just beautiful and it has a
very strong powerful presence to it when
you see it in person
thank you